yeah hello welcome to our monday evening
broadcast sorry for the delay six
minutes late I claimed technical
problems but the main technical problem
was this one yeah i was just doing
something extremely stupid with the
stream so everything's good now I think
so let's get some games going here for
the five-minute rule okay and I get to
play mr. Yaakov anko right away
Grandmaster Demetria ko Blanco 2700
something so what is he going to do here
against my offbeat Spanish yeah that's a
sideline but it's a line that I think is
interesting let's see what we get here
Knight f6 year I cannot remember
thinking I have six is fine it's one of
those lines that i want to check but not
yet gotten into it so cheeks d 5 take
night before i'm not sure about rookie
aid I think I'll play this it's
interesting i haven't played b5 here in
this position so yeah I wonder I wonder
I wonder probably just a little prep
move how to play now play Bishop g4 hmm
it doesn't really put much pressure on
him it's funny without p5 it's really a
bit of a different different position
Bishop g4 I'm probably play Bishop e3
then not quite sure it's a bit unusual
here and then he then he closes the
position okay let's see 37 I guess ya 2d
seven or to see eight I don't have an
ideal setup in a king's indian structure
here that's a webmaster Demetria Vanko
his 2700 something so let's see ok he
will play Queen d2 problem yeah so now
do I play some c5 trying to block that
or it looks like a good kings in the end
for him now
okay i want to stop them direct
steamroller with before even though that
makes my d6 pawn quite weak ok it
doesn't even take yeah it's very
difficult to get an f5 here I mean I'm
maybe I should be in try to be honest
Bishop to g5 would be good if I can get
it in
okay so he basically said point taken
I'd I go back yeah maybe Bishop g5
anyway yeah it's got this Bishop on c6
but how much is this actually doing with
the bishop 16 he's not covering at five
anymore so potential f5 gets a bit
stronger I know that looks a little bit
like shuffling but I want 97 f 5 now
that the bishop is on c6 and all on c2
haha he goes back yeah so he has he has
spotted my concept here I mean okay he's
not exactly a bad play and so so if I go
at five now am I getting smashed
probably i am but without a five this
position totally sucks so let's go ahead
let's go nie Dage for is probably the
other issue might be eight is not
exactly a move okay let's do this that
probably I won't end well but it's just
what I have to do but is that so bad by
the way um c4 Hanks and if I discover
with the night here h-hi eggs
hmm well isn't clear that's not clear at
all so what's this if i take c for what
is he doing Queenie two and then back I
don't know this is too good to not take
huh now that that wasn't the best way of
playing for white that'sthat's pretty
sure d 5 is hanging now it looks good
yeah it looks pretty good pretty good
for me he's really giving me some hopes
here I have zero out of 5 against the
sky is really crushing me normally as he
should of course in some way but I can't
Queen g7 no 24 is also weird how they
backed back here look g8 and so on yeah
with perfect place is probably win for
black rook g8 or chief form look chief
Forbes what is what is this plan against
this okay if I take
time warning check that's it yes okay
I've got one win against ya comin go now
again besides tons of losses okay guys
that was the highlight of the day I'm
going to log off now go okay let's go
for the next game sorry for not putting
a big attention to the chat it was too
interesting I had to really focus so um
yeah so yeah there are many top GM sir
even in Russia who don't have a
professional chess career you don't you
don't know in case of Yaakov enko and
sometimes they're also involved in
teaching or helping other players this
is something that is happening quite
often that you see strong strong players
just being supportive ok let's see a
team glute that's um no that's actually
my line yeah Corp I don't I've kind of
react up glute yeah the Danish GM and
here I have got a 40 squad so it's
exactly the opposite would mean that in
terms of probability as I just have
broken my string against Jackie Evancho
it probably should beat me now
um good question bi GaN Jin's go any
thoughts on the town memoria I have to
say no I have no particular thoughts the
thing is I am I didn't watch any of the
the broadcasts or or anything else I
just simply was too busy with projects
and I didn't didn't see anything yeah I
noticed that girlfriend lost five in a
row which is crazy for a player of his
standards and especially office solidity
he's not the kind of person who loses
often in the first place and then five
times that's a lot yeah and yeah I
noticed that Kramnik is playing some
really a really an enterprising openings
of course he has played a bit of afore
in the recent month so it's not a
complete surprise that he plays the upon
a bit but he played extremely sharp
stuff Bishop g5 against the night off by
kramnik Wow yeah I'm asking mr. glute
hear what his next move is no Knight f6
I have 90 5 191 is also awkward it's not
so clear what black should play yeah
here I'm taking Quincy six looks
problematic but maybe it's not as bad as
it looks because it looks pretty bad
okay I'm going to do this anyway 96 was
the thing that I've held is a problem or
isn't it
Luke f6 maybe maybe that's his idea but
it that looks weird okay okay let's get
ready for Quincy seven now that's still
not possible okay but if I go Quincy
seven now he probably has rook c8
yeah he has Roxy aid huh that's not
great yeah then I have to probably go
back and ok it was not as effective at a
thought
any thoughts on new pony Archie's
performance he seems to be raising
recently yeah it looks like it right
nepali out she had a good has a good
tournament and he also played very
successfully at the limp yet so he seems
to be in good shape it seems so what do
I do here bishop a six yeah I'm
wondering about a very weird looking
move maybe Bishop 2 i'm wondering about
we should be five what would have played
if he had played g500 i'm taking on your
phone yeah this is a funny idea but I
exchange this to make it six weaker are
you taking a for now it's possible don't
mind this that much f4 is a pretty good
square for the Queen hmm interesting but
I have this
this is a big check on e6 Jack rook e8
possibly to e2 this is still kind of
interesting okay so Jack check so what
to do him rook e8 is still kind of kind
of problematic
not easy femme to find moves 95
threatens look d6 and I can check him
again now 9907 doesn't doesn't really do
the trick so let's go them now let's
still store the strongest team j
attending is very good the f porn is
still very weak should be should be very
good for white so don't don't
immediately win and I trav for chronic
is 41 now his one year younger than I am
as always the the way I remember it
Jeff black yeah I don't know probably I
could have done it quicker somehow i but
i'm happy with the two out of two
against two GMS don't get that in too
often so the next game I should have
gotten some water before the session
yeah chronic is playing impressively
nowadays really interesting i think
probably helped that he and as I think
Peter Svidler said he stopped a viewing
shares as some kind of mathematical
exercise and this is probably a good
thing because it's just a fantastically
skilled player let's see who I get next
year
yeah there are some good players on some
some don't play five minute that we have
a look in the list we have like Jeffrey
Jean on that would be a cool measure but
he never plays five minute as far as I
know yeah I've got the request i would
but somehow unlucky not me hug war which
throat GM in a row ok a guru which is
one of my wood heroes actually a very
strong player let's see what is going up
what is coming up with so at least i get
a line that i know the red tea gambit
and it's possible that i actually know
it better than he does so let's see what
is playing the ec six base set up okay
that's possible okay a good wishes back
in is back in in belgium before was a
funny move that i discovered so yeah
five yeah i know i'm 42 I look at best
41 so um yeah guru witches is a strong
player he's actually the first Grand
Master that I have beaten over the board
a couple of years ago or many years ago
and so the strongest ooh that day so an
interesting position
he tries to shoot for b5 and Bishop e7
ok I'm going to make this regrouping to
f1 yague rich played a plate for turkey
for a number of years but he's back back
to Belgium he was so I think coaching
the Turkish juniors 95 maybe do this
first yeah black has got some counter
play here I do 95 @ seem it's a little
bit Lykke Kings Indian attack here yeah
this is the thing I can go queen age 5
and play it real macho style but it
probably doesn't work but I thought
maybe they have porn
and it takes too long three nights five
I cannot play it that just takes too
long I think you probably have some kind
of f5 and storm
My dear now ishqiya Queen h5 of course
Bishop f8 probably yeah now it's there's
some attack g45 is ridiculous doesn't
work I need I need more pieces quite
clearly i wonder if taking us actually
an idea and this is debatable when my
ideas night takes 90 form
G yeah G for was intimidating
I think he should probably take at four
but
let's see what is playing f5 yes that's
a possibility takes Knight shakes I have
to go Queen g6 mmm wait wait wait wait I
can also go to e5 attacking this pawn
this is prolly stronger techie sex
on Queen g6 I thought Queen f7 not even
sure that that worked but
and i def 69 f-16 it doesn't feel so
convincing I can take h6 that's a funky
move okay is 94 ah 94 m okay maybe I can
go Queen g5 yeah yeah just thought want
eggs and I'm good but maybe I'm seeing
it wrong
maybe maybe had something better him I
don't wouldn't draw that out but it
looks okay yeah okay it's not
threatening to take it 9f for he's ready
to take G to whatever okay M night f4
hmm I just have to find the right
solution here then I'm probably winning
somehow maybe not it takes takes time
warning don't see a very good move
somehow yeah this is this is clearly not
ideal Bishop d6 maybe and it's actually
it's too passive but I couldn't I
couldn't really find a good solution I
was perfectly aware that this is not
ideal a little bit I didn't didn't find
something really great
i swindled out of this what a shame what
a shame nope I wanted to go looking
forward okay that was lost anyway yeah
that that's a shame that's a shame I
should have really won this game around
here no no I'm sorry ha you wanted to
rematch in somewhere around here I'm
probably winning but I couldn't maybe
here I just tween f6 and it's over yeah
I was very I was not thinking that this
should be great but before I have don't
have something great okay so third Grand
Master took me down now play either here
from Japan it was very good it was very
good a good companion to the Kings
Indian defense for black yeah yeah I
only play in the five-minute for so I
don't do rematches the Queens gambit
declined just make some sense for sure
you should be true
okay I don't quite remember 93 is the
most option to move
if you think the Kings Indian defense is
solid then what what exactly the bank is
spenco serious has been released on
chesil but you can also go on my channel
and find the info so if I have to go
back now which is not ideal yeah that
wasn't wasn't optimal the optimum here
but I still have some bank on style and
compensation okay so he's just trading
not so stuff normally he'd d5 itself is
enough enough source of counter play I
hope that is that it is the case
speaking of chess cons and I think it's
safe to say now that are also on doing
something something for the ICC going to
do a video series for the ICC which is
probably going to be released the end of
the year will be a huge series on the
middle game the endgame ok so here I've
got a huge time advantage sometimes help
if you know the opening ok I'm going to
see want to do here twin to see three
maybe check I go here just a tech d5 so
it just gives me the gifts me the pawn
takes takes rook e1 yeah ok this is very
dry unfortunately hmm it's difficult not
to do it down
yeah it's a little bit lame but I didn't
find anything better than this
maybe he has some play a he plays it
actively now with Knight e5 Knight g5
stuff I can take the beep on
yeah there's nothing like a good book
man and I understand I understand that
people like books I also do but I can
tell you one thing a book is an
absolutely terrible thing economically
for someone who produces chess content
it's absolutely disastrous so I'm happy
that there are other possibilities like
ICC for videos or whatever and there are
many good resources
yeah I have to use my see ponyo no doubt
about that i'm giving away aged 6 to
have this running check I don't even
know if this makes any sense to be
honest if I chase the rook maybe this
one taking on FC three in the news Oh
with 43 no that's a bad line 43 Bishop
takes c3 is bad like it's just a tempo
down in a very temple critical line so
this is actually really bad so I don't
even consider it playable I try to make
it work but it doesn't
yeah rooks is six kingdon so he probably
has to trade I don't think moving the
rock just make much sense at least I
don't see where exactly you should go
okay now now rook g4 is drawing i wonder
if i can win
hmm cam probably not it's not really
obvious how I could possibly win this
time warning yeah it's probably it's
probably just a draw check check co-ed
one
yeah I wonder if I'm actually quick
enough here now he's got two chords
at least I have easy moves I think am i
winning this here chick no I have to do
this it's probably a drawl right a bit
disappointing but ok I thought I might
might be able to win it yaku venko again
what is he doing now d for maybe give me
a bank o or E for again if I again so
the same opening it would probably do
better right he plays the same line I
mean obviously had a good position so I
completely understand I wonder how I can
improve
it's a bit unusual for me and in the way
I usually go with C 5 early on and I
don't have c5 in him and they don't get
it easily played actually i mean i
piayed looks fairly weird 45 it's kind
of the same as the game before but okay
at least it's a fighting position now it
doesn't have to look it up I mean he had
a great position
hmm okay is that okay I mean what is
probably better here but I don't feel
this is so terrible if I can get the
bishop traded it isn't terrible like h5
King f7 or does he have a tech December
check here ignite age five and I that
that won't work that doesn't work now
forget the bishop traded this position
isn't half bad of course he still has
more space but this is not completely
completely wrong for black Bishop a form
i wonder about b5 I know that's to
weakening okay yeah the Arch Angel
variation again sir we that's a good
line I've thought about this line for my
own repertoire but it's a little bit
thing well how come to say this I I
don't quite understand that I think it's
my problem okay so his idea is to arrest
me here with night f5 night h5 business
I think this is interesting threatening
age for maybe he plays age for himself
but this this is weakening
by the way in the I lost all the four
games before the session against the
Aquaman co but oh no I have be five this
is something I will play takes Queen
takes I grab the beep on okay maybe this
isn't all that clear okay and I've
played them before I'd had very good
positions i was just screwing them up so
getting some some reventon okay how do i
activate now at age 52 f for obviously
would be cool just this g4 isn't so easy
white what to play against efore for
winning chances and you don't want to
play your five you're more of a
positional player mmm there are some
options I would probably recommend them
recommend a Sicilian that is not overly
sharp for example on the the time model
or the Kalashnikov Sicilian lines like
that these are more strategical in
nature thinking about night h 7 8 f 5
here in this position yeah and this i
was actually not really taking into
account but if he go screen to be six
okay i have Luke c2 here for some
activity
isn't that somewhat dangerous I mean
like group g2 nigera see this this is
kind of interesting how can is of course
playa by yes but I don't think I don't
rate the winning chances so I if you if
this is an this is a concern I would
really recommend the Sicilian if you
want conflict so I'm kind of curious
what he is playing here rookie won
something like that to move like Quincy
eight that is interesting for Quincy
three very very sharp okay okay I really
think this is dangerous when 94 doesn't
work Quincy 8 is very close to working I
wonder if g5g for is actually possible I
mean it's just taking pawns here that's
really not that big of a deal oh I
didn't think about this move okay
and I'd f5 who
at the end there is not a for though I
mean
now therefore is also something
breathing let's see it i don't i don't
see it this is such a clear thing sorry
for not is the Kalashnikov a first-rate
opening up you can certainly play it i
guess you're not a 2900 players so why
not play the Kalashnikov okay so i don't
know if i can avoid the repetition here
i can take before right playing forward
from quincy to in this winning I'll come
on come on
okay didn't find anything better but I
mean is this is not bad check check
check check check check check why yes
again whoa 2 2 2 2 wins against jackal
Fink oh and I usually just get my butt
kicked by him so badly whoa ok so
another game whoo okay somehow I kept
this thing together and it was trickier
it was tricky probably many things
missed by both both players yeah I
didn't really look so much as a chat
sorry guys have those super strong
opponents and if I look at the chat and
do all kinds of things it will be 10
very very difficult so i have a new
request out yeah i'm actually pretty
tired I'm very surprised that it works
works out so well but sometimes you're
just lucky everything kind of falls into
places so new request
yeah that position was very awkward for
whites a player with the here's
something like that with my nights all
over the place and so on it's a pretty
awful for wide to play this position
yeah I've got to request our wooden
start pitch us let's see ok I have
played him actually before I'd lost so
I'm warned ok yeah this line i recently
had on the board with ya uh-huh always I
always thought that this is quite um oh
isn't he six-week now yes my CC series
will be a middle game ending focused
thing and I haven't played the bangko
over the board since my childhood days
but it's something I wanted to play it
about a week ago in in a serious very
serious game in the german league but my
opponent avoided it with the with the
Queen pawn opening I think it's
something that I would would play in
over the war chest against the right or
position I think if I play like a 2600
grandmas and sometimes I do it's
probably not what I want to play with
black I think something safer is good
but it's something too it's a good thing
to happen your repertoire if you play
open events and want to want to win
games ok so how would you how to do this
here you will probably take what is six
anyway bh5 and so on
Karine f3 in the 93 Karl Kani is that
really great if black takes on a form i
think the regular two nights what I
played here is pretty good I mean slight
advantage for white maybe not much but
you can hope for a slight edge
yeah al-farouq is seven here trying to
put the book on the 7th edge for
intended to push the H porn all the way
up the board okay here yeah rook c8
probably coming and then king of eight
so i don't really it doesn't really help
all that much p 3 C 4 is what I want to
play yes good counting drop in the chat
I'm upon up so yeah I want my king
involved so let's bring the King up make
it join I didn't think about this move
but I think I can play this I have the
night very much under control here oh
wow giving me a big big porn the night
is a blockade I yes but I can play
Bishop they are all this let's do this
first
you can start with this one and then
Bishop f4 the order isn't really a big
deal but maybe I can can enter quickly
Jack King takes is actually interesting
Jack oh this is fine right age for f5
should do the trick his rook is not
exactly great on d6 yeah look g7 is to
show off move but we can just do this
King 36 should end this
yeah here the night is pretty good check
check check hmm just no stalemate please
black result yeah okay he lost the porn
earlier on and never got any serious
compensation for it okay let's go for
one more game had the slate starts I'm
going to play one more so what did i do
we actually I lost against reverse right
and I have two out of two against Yaakov
anchor which is crazy you were the same
line that I don't know funny the London
with to Bishop f4 yeah currently popular
the two nite system against the Kirkland
this is relatively low theory yes this
is one one positive side this line is
easy to learn it's not so much theory
and it has some idea so it's a good
weapon especially for players who don't
want to study tons of theory the most
promising line against the caricom is
them advanced variation but you know
this is extremely extremely high
theoretical effort to learn and this is
easy to play you often get comfortable
positions it's a kind of thing where
2,800 would probably equalized with
precise play but not everybody plays
that well so it's something that I can
recommend
for ya for for regular use a club
players in particular the London with
Bashir to would do do you know to play
game I have some ideas yes but not next
but I think black has a couple of couple
of Food lines the King's gambit bye bye
Martha bollocks okay so let's play
something really funky with the Adelaide
couch again but this is not what you
should do against the Kings Kings gambit
because you have so many strong lines
that it's pretty idiotic in some way to
play to play something that is so sharp
but yeah you know it's fun d5 I think
this is possible Jay
yeah this should be good for black right
I have forever extremely extremely weird
position here but I've got four minor
pieces here that are all going to be
very active and he's got no development
and the Queen on funky h8 no in the two
nights it doesn't matter which night to
move first caricom yeah matter bollocks
let's that's your queen body like reason
okay then any level loose that that
doesn't really count as a real game so
let's do another one yes this was
probably probably not aligned that the
white playhead on the radar much I think
it just doesn't work that well Bishop c4
him if I remember correctly I think
yeah l eight count again but I I don't
know there are probably some good things
against us let's see I've got the
request out and we have some really
still some very good players on there
are a couple of guys who haven't we
don't play five-minute anymore and some
I would really like to play again like
Larry Christians and then Larry was
playing a lot of five-minute years ago
and there are always lots lots of fun
and I play the cow can once in a while
against the right opponent in tournament
chess I i play it sometimes if I know
that the opponent doesn't play the drums
because I have lots of respect for the
advanced variation the French Rubinstein
that's a very solid choice why not if
you don't mind the odd draw because it
is solid but a bit bit dry or getting
guru which again um okay so we probably
play the same stuff almost the same
stuff add this line this is this is an
interesting line I play that myself with
black the cucumber gambit that's
probably a good gambit
but make sure you don't have any don't
have any cats around with the cucumber
gambit
err Queenie to hook t1b 3 has a good set
up against his opening here even though
you cannot expect to review the black
game at Sur it's not all that bad as i
said i have played this a bit myself
with with black mostly in blitz chess at
middle game if we add structure i have
to say that yeah probably probably
that's okay yell area still has some has
good good stuff on the ISS see with this
attack with larry she is small attack
with larry see show
I know we can actually take the form and
the night hangs okay now how does the
cucumber gambit work
bishop age six what's also interesting
maybe he still has an ID at five Bishop
d3 looks a bit weird now I don't I don't
have a CAD know and I probably don't
think i would try the cucumber thing I
think it's it's somewhat cruel I think
they they are genuinely we need it is
hilarious and early i agree with its
probly bit cruel on the on the animals
they are really genuinely frightened
it's not like it's it's fun for them
think I probably okay 94 rootsy to take
stakes nuts is recheck okay but maybe if
he goes he doesn't do it uh-huh ok so i
will trade this and no I'm blundering FB
50 I just I just totally overlooked
before hanging oh that's a shame
whoa
ah that sets really I hate this kind of
thing it was it wasn't very comfortable
this position but it would have been a
ton of work to win and I just blundered
this stuck in one more yeah 92 of course
he wouldn't know wow wow I thought that
was kind of mandatory but of course he's
just like 10 times the better ending
player
I thought you should just allow
okay i just i just take the stuff now
just try to to just simplify
time warning should this shouldn't this
be possible to hold ya things about
asking about my chess team we're not
doing that well I have to say of course
we we had to go to the third league
again after being after getting last
place in the second league but Jack it
was kind of to be expected not a total
surprise
should be 39 t XG 695 Giselle I cannot
calculate too quick I got the bloody
fault okay man yeah yeah I actually had
to draw in the back here but it didn't
didn't manage it ma'am no telling no
time no no this is this is also I bishop
me 18 wins yeah I was I was kind of
thinking the Jeep one must be strong
with whatever maybe I shouldn't have
answered the team question anyway um
yeah I wasn't wasn't that great yeah we
were relegated on our third leak and we
lost the first match in the third League
the third leak is still very strong and
we need to get a win in soon it was a
pretty tough year in the second league
where we got our butts kicked that yeah
that badly ok guys thanks for watching
the stream it was fun I guess many grand
master scopes could have been one more
here they would have done that correctly
but I was still happy with with the
results thanks a lot for watching and
I'll be back next week bye bye